if you've been yearning to take the
lesson in gaming punishment that is the
sole series to your mobile device bandai
namco officially have you sorted with
Android and iOS game /e souls the free
16-bit mobile game is a spinoff of the
main series and belongs to the endless
runner genre you'll be avoiding traps
slashing it big bad guys and ultimately
trying to avoid that infamous you died
screen the game has been released by
souls series publisher bandai namco in
partnership with video game retail at
Gamestop according to Namco slashy Souls
is inspired by Dark Souls but isn't
directly related to the main series that
said the publisher are promising you'll
die a hell of a lot as with most endless
runner type games and there will be
various weapons spells and bosses /e
soul seems to have had a pretty brutal
reception so far but don't take my word
for it the game is out now on Android
and iOS so give it a play if you feel so
inclined let me know in that comment box
what you think of this one and check
back to GameSpot for everything Dark
Souls